faut prodiguer les jettent à la poubelle
résultat après dj bobo
[Musique]
ma mesure pour l'océan c'est la lutte
contre les plastiques et notamment les
micro plastiques
faut que
tous les habitants de la planète se
disent que lorsqu'il fume une cigarette
et qu'il jette au caniveau leurs mégots
celui ci finit à la mer et mettra des
centaines d'années avant de disparaître
ma mesure pour l'océan c'est tout
simplement de le regarder dans les yeux
de le considérer
donc il faut que tous ceux y compris
ceux qui ne vivent pas au bord de
l'océan se disent que l'océan n'est pas
une poubelle que l'océan c'est notre vie
voilà
l'été des déchets
il ya un premier jet bourbourg ça pollue
appiah ladies a pu étouffer les tortues
ma mesure pour l'océan ce serait d'avoir
absolument un minimum de 30 % d'aires
marines protégées avec des zones de
protection forte
en fait dans les aires marines protégées
on a droit de faire des projets
industriels de chaluter de pêcher de
faire des activités qui sont
envahissantes et destructrice du milieu
marin donc les aires marines protégées
en france à l'heure actuelle sont des
coquilles vides meyers à ma mesure pour
le sien
mesure pour pour l'océan c'est de le
préserver en respectant des
approvisionnements raisonnée de saison
tout en limitant
les composants comme le plastique ou
tout élément qui pourrait qui pourrait
unir notre priorité ici au sein de
police c'est de changer le regard sur
l'océan
émerveiller les petits et les grands et
pour faire en sorte contre le moment où
il rend tellement où ils sortent leur
regard sur l'océan a changé et leurs
comportements changent même mesure pour
l'océan c'est avant tout de tout faire
pour que nos enfants et nos petits
enfants trouvent l'océan dans le même
état y voir le méta meilleur que celui
que nous avons héritée de nos parents
cette préservation pour les générations
futures doit être le souci des
principales mesures qui doit être en
chine ici le reste